hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
fear and trembling is a philosophical
work and it deals primarily with faith
understood as trust and as passion not
simply as credence or belief and in it
Kierkegaard is engaging in philosophy so
one of the key questions that is is
raised at one point in the preliminary
expectoration section is what can
philosophies orientation to faith be
what should it be
and by contrast what should it not be
oftentimes being the case in his own
time so he tells us a few things here
that we can piece together into a
full-blown perspective on the
relationship between philosophy and
faith but he doesn't go much further
with this and it's important to keep in
mind that he is writing this as he does
so often in his works under the guise of
a pseudonym in this case it's Johannes
to Silencio who appears to himself be a
philosopher or at least somebody who has
studied philosophy is conversant with
the philosophy of his time and he has
some very definite opinions on that as
well as on faith and theology and you
know what we can say is that Kierkegaard
is really going to give us two sets of
ideas that he's proposing to us
proposing very strongly one is criticism
of contemporary philosophy of his own
time largely Hegelian ISM but it could
extend to many other ways of
understanding philosophy as well so he's
criticizing the attitudes that many
people in his own culture and
intellectual milieu are setting out of
the relationship between philosophy and
faith and then he's elaborating for us a
different model a model in which
philosophy is remaining a bit more true
to its own spirit and mission so let's
look
the criticism first he tells us at a
number of points in this work not just
in this section but but throughout the
entire thing that so many people in his
culture want to you know begin with some
sort of understanding of faith and then
go beyond faith and he also says they
want to do this with the figure of
Abraham the idea is that well you know
Abraham he's got this relationship with
God or the divine or whatever we want to
call it spirit and it's very primitive
it's very crude we don't want to be
beholden to that we want to take
whatever is really essential the lesson
we can learn from it and then get rid of
all that other Stone Age garbage that
that is really just cluttering things up
and when we express it this way I think
you can see that there's not only a lot
of people in Kierkegaard's own
enlightened age who espoused viewpoints
like that there's many people in our own
age as well who view religious faith or
some of its key figures as these
rudimentary starting points that have
some lessons to teach us but we need to
really strip away all the dross and
leave that stuff behind and then call
out the few nuggets of you know whatever
we want to call it perennial philosophy
eternal wisdom you know liberal ideas
for the age pick whatever tagline you
like and Kierkegaard thinks that that's
a really fundamental mistake why would
that be a mistake
well because faith is not something to
begin with as a launching pad and then
leave behind it's actually something
that is very difficult to attain and
that you have to work towards and might
be receding from you yes you're moving
towards it using the means of philosophy
or whatever other intellectual apparatus
you would you would prefer in that place
so having this attitude that
viii is something to go beyond is going
to be quite problematic he's got a
wonderful line in there about Abraham
and about Hegelian philosophy says it's
supposed to be a difficult to understand
Hegel but to understand Abraham is a
small matter now it is difficult to
understand Eagle in part because Hegel
does not express himself well but also
because Hegel is working with quite
complicated concepts and there's this
entire developmental view that's quite
true right but as Abraham dumber than
Hegel is Abraham less expressive is
there less to teach us he says to go
beyond Hegel is a miraculous achievement
but to go beyond Abraham is the easiest
of all and he says I from my own part of
applied considerable time to
understanding a Galilean philosophy I
believe I've understood it fairly well
I'm sufficiently brash to think when I
can't understand particular passages
despite all my pains he himself may not
have been entirely clear this I do
easily naturally without any mental
strain so he's saying I understand the
Hegelian philosophy I may not be you
know the preeminent scholar or
practitioner of it but I get it now what
about Abraham so thinking about Abraham
is an entirely different matter I am
shattered
I am constantly aware of the prodigious
paradox that is the content of Abraham's
life I am constantly repelled and
despite all its passion my thought
cannot penetrate it cannot get ahead by
a hair's breadth I stretch every muscle
to get a perspective and at the very
same instant I become paralyzed now
notice what Kierkegaard is not saying
there he's not saying oh well you know I
didn't understand it the first time or
the second time so it must not be
comprehensible because if it's not
understandable to me as the sort of
representative of what really is or the
adjudicator of what really is
understandable then it must not be
understandable in itself he's saying no
there is a paradox there is
something that resists my rational
efforts to make sense of it before me
and I am trying my hardest to understand
it it's not a fault of the content the
way it might be in hegel hegel being
unclear at points being wrong at points
it's rather me the rational agent trying
to make sense of it who may not be up to
the task so if that's the case then we
probably shouldn't try to you know leap
beyond Abraham or faith in an instant
another example of a criticism that he
makes philosophy he says disparages
faith and give something else in its
place
he says philosophy should not do this
it's not really being faithful to its
own goals its own mission if it's doing
that why should philosophy not disparage
faith we have a lot of philosophical
perspectives that do in fact disparage
faith and not in the sense of saying I
want to understand this faith they say
look this is all garbage these religious
believers they're deluded they are
mistaken they are within the grips of
their own desires and passions they're
projecting something out there that
doesn't really exist here Kierkegaard
doesn't go deeply into this question
here about whether that's a legitimate
position for a philosophy that wants to
remain true to itself as philosophy to
take but he does sort of set out his own
view on this philosophy shouldn't be in
the business of disparaging faith maybe
faith isn't something that philosophy is
really that competent at least in
certain respects to say something about
he doesn't say that by the way that
philosophy shouldn't disparage
superstition or the co-option of
religious beliefs by political systems
or anything like that as a matter of
fact later on in this he will say that a
church is really very much like a state
you know both of them are to be
distrusted but he does think that
philosophy shouldn't be in the business
simply of disparaging faith this
missing it what else
philosophy wants to give something in
place of faith philosophy wants to say
here's what faith really is or here's
the nugget of truth in it here you go
religious believers have this instead
wouldn't you be better off with this
sort of thing then that crude stupid
anthropomorphic thing that you believe
in and practice and Kierkegaard is
saying that you know if philosophy wants
to be honest he says philosophy cannot
and must not give faith you know but it
shouldn't give something else in its
place so then the question is well great
where are you supposed to get faith and
he is going to leave that unanswered at
this point notice one other thing -
before we go into what philosophy ought
to be doing about the conception of
philosophy that he has here and this is
a conception of philosophy that cannot
really be avoided even by those who make
an attempt to avoid it
philosophy is one of those activities of
the human mind that is total izing it
attempts to make sense out in principle
out of everything it attempts to extend
itself to everything it may not in fact
be competent to do so and we're not just
talking about the competency of
particular individual philosophers we're
talking about the competence sort of in
principle of the entire discipline or
activity one of the key questions that
is raised for philosophy by philosophy
itself in relation to other disciplines
is can philosophy go over there into the
domain of other disciplines and tell
them what they ought to be doing or make
full judgments about what they're doing
or fully understand what they're up to
or are there certain limits beyond which
philosophy perhaps either shouldn't
cross or shouldn't cross and expect its
competence to be respected shouldn't
tell itself that it belongs there on
that side of the limit many philosophers
in the past
and even in the present even those who
would like to limit philosophies own
pretensions in certain ways in a
philosophical way often do not respect
that that set of limits that are imposed
by the other objects of human thought
and activity so he tells us that
philosophy should do several things one
is it just a little bit later he's
talking about the dialectic of faith and
he says it's commonly supposed that what
faith produces is no work of art that is
a coarse and boorish piece of work only
for the most uncouth nature's crude
right and then he says but it's far from
being that the dialectic of faith is the
finest and most extraordinary of all it
has an elevation of which I can
certainly form a conception but no more
than that so notice that Kierkegaard
here is not saying faith over there
hands-off philosophy you've got no
business whatsoever
he's saying philosophy can indeed form a
conception of what faith is up to but it
can't do more than that it doesn't
understand it fully it doesn't provide
the blueprint for it faith if it wants
to teach philosophy can teach philosophy
something about itself and about its
dialectic so what should we do we should
form a conception of the dialectic of
faith we should in fact employ
philosophy to do so that is a legitimate
use of that activity that rational
pursuit what else he goes on and he says
that philosophy should indeed understand
itself this is in that passage that I'll
not read he says I by no means conclude
the faith is something inferior but
rather that it's the highest and that
it's dishonest of philosophy to give
something else in its place and to
disparage faith we saw that just a
little bit earlier says philosophy
cannot and must not give faith
but here's a key but at this point it
must understand itself and know what it
offers and take nothing away
least of all trick men out of something
by pretending that it is nothing that
faith is nothing now you might say well
why does philosophy have to understand
itself this again is integral to the
classic conception of philosophy a
philosophy that does not make an attempt
to understand itself its own activities
its own limitations is not really much
of a philosophy it becomes something
like an ideology or like a set of
algorithms or like a set of instructions
about how to do something that has no
reflexive capacity and that would
invalidate it as philosophy if you put
it side by side with philosophy that
actually does try to understand itself
that does attempt to make sense out of
itself that would be a significant
problem
would it not what else he brings up this
this idea of faith and he uses two
different terms here as being higher
than and being beyond what it is that
philosophy can do so philosophy cannot
dominate analyze put something in its
place for faith and it actually has to
recognize that faith is in a certain
sense greater than philosophy and that
is something that philosophy can in fact
do it will be very uncomfortable for
most philosophers to do that but that
does not mean that philosophy cannot or
should not do that
and if we follow Kierkegaard's
conception that he's laying out here
what this means is that philosophy is
always going to be in the position of a
learner or you might say a beginner when
it comes to faith rather than being the
expert talking down
- and giving rules to faith and you
might bring up one other question here
just to bring this to a close is this a
reversion to what we might call the
medieval understanding of philosophy as
the handmaiden of theology the answer is
no because Kierkegaard actually has a
very dim view of the theology of his
time he says that love has its priests
and the poets who speaks to the honor of
the passion of faith he says philosophy
goes further theology sits rouged and
powdered in the window and courts
philosophies favor offers its charms to
philosophy he's saying essentially sort
of reversing Luther's dictum that reason
is a [ __ ] that theology is in fact
acting like a prostitute and taking
faith and putting it out in front of
philosophy in order to sell it which
makes theology something pretty bad so
we don't have you know a simple
subordination of philosophy to theology
instead we might say we have faith as a
kind of limit beyond which philosophy is
drawn but also extends beyond its own
competence and it is philosophical for
philosophy to recognize that so that is
one key idea governing this work and
hopefully that that will help you
understand the approach Kierkegaard is
taking
you